when most people think of cycling they
think of the steep hills and thrilling
Sprint's of the Tour de France but one
of the sports oldest and most coveted
records is something called the hour
record it's very simple
one person one bike riding for one hour
on a track like this how much distance
can they cover the first official record
was set in the late 1800s and since then
many of the Great's of the sport have
attempted the hour today the men's
record is fifty four point five to six
kilometers or just under thirty four
miles for women it's forty eight point
zero zero seven kilometers just shy of
30 miles so can somebody ride even
farther today we're gonna look at why
riding sixty kilometers in one hour
is almost impossible to find out what it
takes
I tried riding as hard as the current
record-holder discuss the pain of riding
that hard for a full hour
with someone who's done it all your body
is you're screaming stop stop good very
good and working the sports scientist to
find out what my body is capable I still
choose into the 50s perfect that's
excellent the hour record has been
called the purest of all cycling races
but actually doing it is anything but
simple it's become a team effort with
designers coaches and athletes all
trying to roll just a bit further they
use state-of-the-art tools like wind
tunnels and power meters to gain every
competitive advantage no detail is too
small you have the wheels the frame the
helmet in the shape of that helmet you
know we can get somebody to save quite a
bit of drag but first you've got to have
the strength and stamina to push hard
for an hour the hour record is a very
personal endeavor it's all about you
your machine and how much power you can
put out for 60 minutes straight it's
usually a lot of power and
to be very consistent it's a lot harder
than it sounds but today I'm gonna try
to maintain the same power as the
current men's world-record holder and
just see how long I can last to help me
today is Evelyn Stevens she's a former
our record holder herself and she is
going to be controlling the machine that
I'm currently peddling away on Stevens
retired from racing in 2016 but before
she did she set a new our record by
riding an incredible 47 point nine eight
kilometers almost 30 months and our
records proved to be one of the most if
not the most challenging because I did
very my career there's a lot that goes
into the hour but one way that cyclists
look at racing these days is through
something called power output it's
measured in watts a bike commuter might
generate about 100 watts pro sprinters
can generate nearly 2,000 watts but only
in short bursts the hour is all about a
steady prolonged power it's kind of a
meditative process in a masochistic way
when Stevens set her record she kept up
an output of around 300 watts for a full
hour Bradley Wiggins
who has the current men's record is
estimated to have cranked out 440 watts
for an hour so what kind of power output
am i having right now so Robbie you're
currently going 150 watts okay and how
much power do I need to put out we're
gonna need to get you to 440 watts
okay so next up 200 all right Stephens
used an app to increase the wattage on
my trainer which made it harder and
harder for me to pedal okay you're now
at 200 all right your 250 how's it
feeling hard ready for the next yeah
let's take it to 300 let's get there oh
that's way harder if I watch you
increase it like that so Evelyn I've
heard that when you're actually trying
this record you aren't actually allowed
to look at your power output no when you
do the record you have no data
whatsoever so you have no power no rpm
note
I'm no distance nothing you are just it
is truly you in your machine okay I
think this is kind of a probably an
uncomfortable level so I think we should
keep going
let's go right so go right to 400 okay
we're at 401 okay which we just go right
to 440 yeah okay you're 441 we're gonna
be full of extra so remember he did this
for 60 minutes all right you guys what
was that about 30 seconds
I think Robbie can you do it for an hour
no I think you held that for about 45
seconds god that was ridiculous
you'd have to hold that more than 60
times longer than I held it yeah and
actually focus on where you're going and
you do it from a standing start
oh that sounds miserable that misery is
what cyclists call the pain cave and
enduring it before a full hour is
incredibly difficult Stephens told me
that she nearly cracked with only a few
minutes left
during her attempt there was I think
about minute 50 to 55 of our record I
lost it and that's because I was
physically in the most beautiful place
I've ever been to come anywhere close to
setting an endurance record like the
hour you have to be physically gifted
and one of the greatest gifts a cyclist
can have is a Monstress vo2 max it's a
measure of how good your body is at
getting oxygen out of the air and into
your tissues vo2 max is a value that we
test in the lab and we identify because
really sets the upper limit of how much
energy can be produced that is Neal
Henderson he's the sports scientist who
coach Stevens to her record and Rowan
Dennis to his both athletes have massive
vo2 max numbers
the thing is vo2 max output can only be
sustained for maybe 5 or 10 minutes
well trained athlete but a pro athlete
can perform at a level just below their
vo2 max for quite a bit longer than that
that level is called their anaerobic
threshold to find it you measure
something called lactate in the blood
too much lactate and the effort can't be
sustained those two tests in concert
tell us what that absolute ceiling is
and then how close to that ceiling you
can redline and hold to find my limits
Henderson put me through the same
exercise that Stevens did but this time
he sampled my blood while I rode on the
stationary bike 6.8 we blew through
finally so you got a 2.1 millimole
change on that stage that clearly
indicates that you were basically
lactate was coming out of over the top
then he tested my vo2 max so this is a
two-way valve so he's gonna be breathing
in and getting air from out here and
then as he exhales it's gonna lock that
off and then what he exhales is going to
go in through here into the analyzer
this doesn't look intimidating at all
same deal I wrote harder and harder and
he measured my oxygen levels I reached
this point where I kept telling myself
like ten more seconds ten more seconds
ten more seconds right like I can do 10
more seconds but around halfway through
the 3:20 stage my body was just like no
can't do ten more seconds Iran tastic
what was my vo2 max your vo2 max the
absolute peak got into the 50s and in
fact 50 2.5 milliliters of oxygen per
kilogram of body weight per minute which
is very good I don't think you're gonna
set an hour record tomorrow with that
but that is well above an average value
so an Evy's value is what 72-73 the
number of people on earth with vo2 max
is in the 70s is just vanishing very
small yeah women in the 70s is like men
amis there's
okay so I'm definitely not a contender
for the our ring but that doesn't mean I
can't try to get faster I went to bike
manufacturers specialized to get a pro
fit on a bike very similar to the one
that Stevens used to set her record
but first a new happen then I got a
custom totally pro level treatment from
specialist Aaron post
Wow yeah this is super aggressive
already yeah he used an LED motion
capture system to dial in every aspect
of my position on the bike yeah he just
did your first 180 on a bike my friend I
figured I wanted to get as low as
possible to minimize wind resistance but
post says that's not always the case
the arrow position is only arrow when
you're in the arrow position it doesn't
matter how cool your bike looks in
transition area or sitting out there for
the photo shoot before you go for an
hour record if you can't stay in those
Aero bars you're not going to be faster
he's right staying in arrow position can
be limiting to low and it makes it hard
to breathe
it can even restrict blood flow with my
fit dialed in I went into this beast
it's called the wind tunnel WI n get it
all right you're gonna go fast right
most wind tunnels are for testing cars
and aircraft this one is made for people
Evelyn Stephens perfected her our record
position here
I tried riding in slightly different
positions while the team had specialized
captured my aerodynamics data I tried
the lowest possible arrow bar position
for my fitting and then I tried at 2
centimeters higher which felt a lot
better
why so much focus on this because
handlebars matter a lot to the hour
record in the 1990s racer started
exploiting unconventional and profoundly
aerodynamic handlebar positions like the
praying mantis the arms tucked up
to the shoulders chris boardman set what
is now called the absolute our record at
fifty six point three kilometers
this the Superman position arms
stretched out into an air slicing Dart
but in 1997 the rules changed everyone
had to use classic drop bars and under
those constraints no one could touch the
absolute record but then in 2014 the
rules changed again allowing for a sort
of in-between position arrow bars like
these don't slice the wind like the
Superman did but they're way faster than
drop bars alright so what the results
show all right so your baseline position
again was the most aggressive and lowest
that we thought you could sustain in the
fit lab if we raise the pads to
centimeters because you said that hey
that lower position might not be
sustainable especially over an hour so
we raise it the two centimeters and for
you it turned out that that position was
actually absolutely no different in the
aerodynamic drag
so as an athlete that's a win-win you're
able to hold the position you're able to
generate more power and there's no
aerodynamic drag penalty now the icing
on the cake on top of all that is with
that higher Pat position you were a lot
more comfortable getting more aggressive
with your head shrug and by doing that
that saved a further about 5% or 15
watts as he from your position which is
enormous when you're trying to go as
fast as possible
to put it all together Henderson took me
to the US Olympic track in Colorado
Springs where Stephen set her record
once you've gotten up to speed hold
right about 200 watts first I wrote it
on a standard track bike given my
measurements 200 watts for an hour
seemed possible
right around 35 35 7 yep but I'd only go
about 35 kilometers just under 22 miles
hardly a record-setting distance so
Henderson swapped out some components
the first thing I'm gonna change out
here is gonna be the front wheel this
will actually make even more difference
than the rear wheel since this is the
leading edge the other thing we do is in
terms of the tire width this is an
extremely narrow
higher on this extremely narrow ribbed
even if I wasn't born with a massive vo2
max I could still be faster you are
aerodynamically enhanced double disc
front rear arrow bars arrow helmet
itsgotime let's see what you got
all right we're gonna go the same target
power 200 watts you're gonna see here
but we should see clearly some
significant increase in your speed next
level all right with the same power
output I was suddenly able to pedal
almost 40 kilometers an hour we're
nearly 25 miles per hour
you just went 10% faster yeah that's
that's big same output 10% faster
another way to look at that is it took
us five minutes to put on about $5,000
with the parts to buy it's about five
kilometers per hour
I looked faster and I definitely felt
faster but I hadn't even approached the
record speeds or tried to crank them out
for 60 minutes remember I couldn't even
do a full minute on the trainer at the
sort of power needed to challenge the
men's record this event isn't about
all-out power it's about metering your
effort just right for an entire hour and
if you overcook it there's a price to be
paid if you start too fast you're trying
to do something that's effectively not
possible these margins are so very small
then if you go over that effort by just
a small amount point five percent
doesn't sound like much you know for a
male cyclist a high level rider that's
literally a couple watts but the cost of
exceeding that can on the end in the
last 10 or 15 minutes cost 10 15 20 50
watts that they can no longer produce
what was just a half a percent too much
for the first 45 minutes and then they
fade out and the speed drops to get a
sense of what the pros experience
Henderson paced me with an electric
motorcycle first I tried riding 48
kilometers an hour the women's speed
record
then I tried the men's speed as you can
see I was wobbling all over the place
it's one thing to try and ride this hard
on a trainer do we get on the track felt
dangerous so we got up the throwing
speed 52 and a half K an hour and about
a lap battle laugh as much as gear and
training matter so does the track
concrete tracks like the one at Colorado
Springs are a little slower than wooden
ones and the tracks location and
altitude make a big difference as well
ultimately a given rider can produce a
certain amount of power output the
amount of power is going to affect the
speed they go but your selection of what
track and where you go is gonna have an
impact on aerodynamics and air density
specifically so when we come up to
altitude like we are here in Colorado
the air is less dense though you also
have a physiological constraint that you
cannot produce quite as much power as
you would at sea level in most cases
there's a benefit though to performing
at altitude especially if you have
conditioning and training being done at
altitudes over here prepares for the
past when Italian racer vitória busi
broke Stephens record she went just 27
meters further when she did it on a
wooden track in Aguascalientes Mexico
it's where many cycling records have
been set ah gross calientes is that
faster track it's at altitude it's about
1,800 meters high so it's just a touch
higher than Boulder here because of the
air density which is really the
barometric pressure and humidity
interactions tends to be much warmer and
then it's a wood 250 meter track versus
a concrete 333 so it's got all the right
characteristics to be very fast how fast
let's just say that I attempted the hour
at 200 watts on this bike with this gear
now I'm not gonna set a record by any
means but the right track could make a
big difference at an outdoor velodrome
like the one in Trexler town
Pennsylvania I would ride 37.3 5
kilometers but in Colorado Springs I'd
get thirty eight point seven five and in
aguas calientes I would jump to
full kilometres and go forty point nine
and that's just the track factoring in
their position and equipment can give an
elite cyclists just enough edge to claim
the record so will we ever see the men's
record hit sixty kilometers or the
women's hit fifty maybe I do believe
that fifty kilometers per hour is
definitely in the realm for the women
they're currently just just under two
kilometers shy of that I do believe that
than then even with the current position
we'll be getting into the fifty five and
even fifty six kilometers maybe fifty
seven to break the 60 kilometre barrier
under current rules Henderson says you
need a person capable of generating 450
watts
while tucked into what would likely be a
very painful arrow position and they'd
probably have to do it in aguas
calientes but until that happens
remember that what athletes are doing
already is almost impossible
[Applause]